- Well, true or false?
I love your beard game, but I did hear
that when you were on Law and Order,
- Uh huh.
- you were asked to get rid of it
because Dick Wolf's wife didn't like it.
- That's the word on the street.
My first 10 on law and order,
back in 2008, 2009, I came with a beard,
not as full as this,
but I came with a beard.
We did a full season and then our second,
my second season on the show, got a call
into Dick Wolf's office.
I thought I was in trouble
and they were like, 'Yeah.'
Jeremy Sisto and I both had beards,
and we thought we were both getting fired
cause we both got called into the office.
- [Kelly] Oh no.
- And basically it was like,
you guys need to shave, tomorrow.
And they worked it into the script
and we had to shave our beards.
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah.
- She is a powerful woman.
- Yeah well, you know what?
- Yeah. Hey. Hey.
- A powerful, yeah.
- Happy wife, happy life.
- Okay.
- You know?
- It does sometimes go the other way.
- Yeah.